management technology gaziabad for this
digital marketing certificate program
which we'll be describing today we're
very honored to have three of the
distinguished faculty members here and
we will introduce them shortly
um fair warning if my
Zoom connection becomes unstable I may
drop off and then drop back on but
won't
won't end the webinar until
so
with that said we're going to talk about
today digital marketing careers then
we'll talk about what this program
offers you in that regard how it gets
you job ready
moves you through enrollment steps and
I'll describe a bonus offer you receive
for being here at this webinar today
we'll do a q a with the professors and
along the way I'll be asking a couple of
poll questions of the audience more
toward the middle and end of the seminar
here
um our guides today are Professor
Sandeep
Professor Bindu Gupta and Professor
subrajit Singh Gupta of IMT gospad and
welcome professors
thank you Stuart okay and
let's move into careers in digital
marketing
uh I think Professor Sundeep
if you'd like yeah thanks to Art so
um
welcome to all of you for attending this
webinar so uh basically what we are
saying that digital uh economy is
basically replacing traditional economy
and every part of the business is going
through digital Transformations so like
uh be it the sales marketing customer
services and all aspect of sales and
marketing and going through it so uh one
can say there are multiple reasons for
it like in India you know there are huge
penetration of 4G and the data uh then
there are platforms like Amazon Flipkart
zomato uh who creates basically huge
amount of data for analysis on which
also connect the buyers and the sellers
and um the it is not only benefiting the
seller but you can see that the
customers or the consumers are also
getting empowered like we do not need to
depend on what the company says but we
basically work on the word of mouth of
other users like who has visited One
restaurant or any Resort and others so
uh that is basically empowering the
consumers also so
um so um let's conclude this Slide by
saying that so every organization need a
digital footprint and the great
organization are doing Omni Channel like
they are trying to integrate their
physical and digital
experience thanks a lot
yeah uh thank you Professor uh Stuart I
think I should take it forward so uh
thank you uh so let's talk about you
know there are how has digital marketing
opened up many skills for in today's
environment uh today you'll find a lot
of companies are offering uh special
skill you know special uh you can say uh
managerial lines where skills of digital
marketing are required right you have
SEO analyst email manager you have a
digital marketing manager you have a
digital Advertiser you have adword
manager so you have different kind of
you have social media strategists social
media managers you have different kinds
of you know um careers coming up in this
area right and that's why it is
important and moreover it's not only
about the companies you know to some
extent digital marketing is very much
required for us uh you know for in an
individual as well so you need to know
so in digital marketing we also talk
about so see we have we are all aware
about how brands have developed over
their ages right one what brands are
doing but have you ever thought that you
are also creating your own brand right
you are creating a you are creating a
space for course something called as
personal branding and that's you are
doing through Linkedin via LinkedIn
right so you are creating so in today's
terms visibility is one of the very
important aspects that is very much
required in the digital space and when
uh users are online brands or online
companies are online everything is
online so somewhere or the other you
need to be visible in that uh you know a
clutter of information as well so how
you cut you know deep into that uh you
know cut the Clutter and make yourself
visible is very important so definitely
starting with digital marketing manager
digital marketing manager is uh you know
an overall hierarchical umbrella where
you have different different it's not
only restricted to any one specific but
all digital activities that a firm takes
intakes right in order to create its
online presence maybe it's a social
media platforms maybe it's you know B2B
businesses platforms like LinkedIn and
all maybe it's uh you know um how it's
working on its different uh analytics
how it's understanding its analytics
what needs to be done what need not to
be done what goes for the company what
doesn't go for the company accordingly
digital marketing manager takes a
control of all of these talk excuse me
talking about email marketing email
marketing managers are very much into
you know you must have seen these this
curated emails come to your picture and
uh into your inboxes and without even
you opening emails you see you know the
message gets delivered so how is the
subject line being designed what is the
pictures that are being uploaded what
are the social media handles that have
been you know tagged in the email so all
these are how the information has been
created you must have heard about you
know mad over marketing so uh if you are
a marketing Enthusiast you must be aware
about mad over marketing and how mad
over marketing does it's you know a
digital marketing campaign so mad over
marketing within every uh you know uh
week they send out something called as
email uh email uh email which which is
termed as chitty so they know that the
Indian uh consumer base is very much
towards something you know can relate to
something as a chitty and you will be
seeing that you know a list of what's
happening in the digital space mad over
marketing do sell okay so that's that's
a kind of you know email marketing uh
that's the job of an email marketing
manager content marketing manager now in
today's Times
talk about anything okay you whatever
you are doing you know whatever you're
doing on social media uh you're clicking
pictures you're capturing pictures
you're uploading your uh case studies
Mark Sheets whatever these are all forms
of content right so content marketing
manager has a huge task to do and
today's Times in today's times we can
say you know content is the King right
we as we all know without relevant
content consumers are not going to be
attracted towards you and uh the content
has to be consistent over over the
period of time right so then only you
must be hearing different kind of you
know stand-up comedians like uh Kusha
kapila uh you can say uh and there are
many more like that right so what kind
of content needs to be kept out and
there are different kinds and different
emotions attached to contents right
anger happiness humor so how are these
content
actually you know catering to the
business and how do Brands relate with
this contents how do consumers relate
with the content so that's why you you
know if you are a fan of uh say mad over
marketing
we will be finding different kinds of
you know uh Instagram posts they are
coming up with and uh definitely people
are keeping on uh following them right
so therefore it's very much importantly
required that you deliver the right kind
of content to your right kind of
audience so this is the job of a content
manager social media strategist with
social media platforms to use when to
use what is the right time to use all
these are strategized by the social
media manager right uh even when you
talk about uh uh so a content is a big
part of social media as well as within
social media also what kind of hashtags
you're using what kinds of platforms
you're using what is your audience
actually looking for so that's very much
and social media is something where you
are not intrigued or you know you're not
looking for actually a lot of
information right where you are you are
somewhere where it's it's your
relaxation time that you're browsing
your social media so a light-hearted
note of providing your information or a
you know very subtle way of providing an
information might work over there rather
than giving you you know a bunch of a
lot of information so how do you curate
your information dissemination process
is a part of a social media strategies
digital advertising talk about you know
different kinds of digital ads they are
coming into the picture so how much
budget to be spent on digital
advertising what kind of digital
advertising to be done should you be
doing a search engine advertising or
should you be doing a display
advertising should you be doing you know
app advertising should you be doing
mobile advertising all these are taken
into consideration as a part of digital
advertising and within digital
advertising how much would you be play
paying for that right so budget is one
of the uh major constraint curating
different kinds of constraints different
kinds of digital ads
and simplifying are very engaging in
their content okay uh PPC marketing
planner so how much for what type so PPC
stands for
pay per click so a campaign runs since
of campaigns running by uh in different
digital platforms uh by different brands
so what is the time period of the
campaign to be run what are the
different kinds of so analyzing those uh
audiences who are clicking on the
content uh how much which websites they
are clicking from which websites to
position those content you know through
position Those ads these are all part of
your PPC uh marketing planner uh
e-commerce managers different kinds of
e-commerce websites are available in
today's time so which kind of products
to be which kinds of products by which
kind of Brands to be available in
different websites right uh and how can
you you will be seeing you know
retargeting ads coming up so once you
have visited Amazon or you have visited
Nika for say and you have seen certain
kinds of products you will be definitely
seeing those uh products suggestions or
based on your purchase pattern onto your
social media platforms okay to make you
convert more and more so these these are
all parts of e-commerce manager what are
the different kinds kinds of you know
what is the consumer Behavior actually
in in e-commerce platforms these are all
part of you know e-commerce manager
website marketing manager so the as we
know that the website of a of an
organization is one of the you know very
critical aspects and websites has to
load within two seconds of if the you
know if the company uh aspires to be on
the top and within the website also
there are different kinds of analytics
involved like how much people are having
bounce rate how much people are spending
time on the where are people clicking
more so all these activities have to be
taken care by the website marketing
manager what is the website structure
how does it flow how does it uh you know
link with other websites so which is
called as backlink so how does that work
so those are all part of you know
website marketing manager and somewhere
or the other SEO analyst also has is
responsible for the website to rank
higher in the search engine result page
be it the Google search engine result
page which is the one of the you know 99
of the dominant in the market stays
while other search engine results are
also there right uh even
um so how does the website rank higher
and higher because you know as you might
know that you know nobody remembers the
person who comes second right so it's
it's also always has to be the top one
so it's the job of the SEO analyst to
make utilization of certain keywords
matching the relevance of the users who
are searching for that specific keyword
to the call it available on the website
so and make sure that the uh you know
website uh that the user finds valuable
insights from the website so that has
also to be taken care of so all these
are somewhere or the other interrelated
to each other however uh it's you know
they are they can be even separated with
each other and they work in coordination
with each other each other digital
marketing manager takes care of you know
all all these digital you know
techniques or all these digital uh uh
you know you can
a
digital lines are actually okay so I
hope I'm able to make sense to all of
you uh we'll take up questions further
okay so over to used word
yeah I just uh yes thank you yeah I just
explains this as well yeah right exactly
so I just wanted to make the point that
for all of these different roles and for
whichever one you might choose as a
specialization for yourself
it's important to understand all of the
skills so that you can interact with
your peers in digital marketing and
coordinate your part of the picture with
everyone else's so
um
important to have that broad range in
the sense of developing t-shaped skills
where you have the broad range of
knowledge and then can specialize in
your particular area so let's ask a
question
for my computer to respond properly
second
this question is what is stopping you
from
taking would have stopped you up to this
point from taking uh digital marketing
certification
because we know everyone in the audience
here today is interested
in digital marketing it's a career area
but you haven't necessarily taken that
step yet so
let us know what concerns you've had
when you've looked at other programs and
I'll close this poll in five seconds
four three
two one
the main question or concern people have
had today is that they feel they
wouldn't get practical exposure
practical experience they could use to
demonstrate their new skills
so we'll talk about that
in the description of this program
and this program is the digital
marketing program
from IMT ghaziabad it is a five month
completely online program and it's
powered by
um
meta so
Professor Gupta did you want to go ahead
and uh
address this a bit
yeah uh thank you sir uh welcome to this
webinar I'm Professor Bindu Gupta at uh
I'm a professor director and OBT I'm not
teaching in this program uh but I am the
program called coordinator so I would
like to share something about time
Institute which is around more than 40
Old Institute established in 1980 it and
it has been consistently ranked among
the top 15 business school in India okay
also IMT has a different accreditation
from the international organizations
like Asus
and also we have at national
accreditation like NBA okay and and The
Institute is really known for his
curriculum and we have uh uh one
different accolades from the different
trade forms and the the what we do at
IMT we ensure we have a diverse
portfolio faculty
uh at the global level and we also do a
lot of trading program lot of
consultancy for many uh public and
private sector organizations like maruti
damodar Valley and SPC and to name uh
just today's few okay
um IMT mainly offer postgraduate program
and we offer program like this
remarketing Finance
operations and HR and also we offer
offer programs for the working executive
like you okay so some program of the
full-time program and some are program
are like with the the technology
Partners like a simply run and we do
offer these programs okay and really and
I really and really Pride that we have a
alumni who are at the key different
positions at that in different
organizations and many of them have
leadership positions in in that in the
knowledge organizations at the national
and the international uh platforms okay
and and uh and to all the candidates who
do the program
like you we also get the uh we give the
associate alumni status to them okay so
we welcome to this program and if you
would like to know more about IMT of
course we'll be updating about this uh
this is from my side thank you thank you
to build this webinar thank you and uh
so now that you have the context of of
the organization that offers it and I'll
just mention that simply learn as
professor said is a delivery partner
um where we make this content available
to you through our platform it's a fully
online platform
and it allows you to do all of your live
classes for the program online so that
you don't need to travel anywhere but
you can access them from your desktop or
laptop device
um other than the live classes which are
on at scheduled times the rest of the
activities in the program can be done at
any time 24 7 on your schedule so it's
very flexible and fits in with almost
everybody's work schedule if you're a
working professional
the curriculum which we'll discuss in a
bit is very comprehensive covers all of
the skills and roles that
discussed earlier and
at the end of the process you receive a
professional certificate
from IMT ghaziabad
um
this attests that you have completed all
of the Core curriculum you have the
ability to take
any electives including master classes
with not just uh faculty but industry
leaders who come in from uh outside
roles and present
lectures monthly you have Hands-On case
study projects which you do on the same
platform so you don't need to switch to
a different platform or download
anything special to accomplish that
you perform a Capstone project which
becomes the
highlight of your personal portfolio of
experience along the way as you do your
projects you're building a portfolio of
experience and that culminates in the
Capstone project
which we'll discuss in a bit you also
take modules uh for that qualify you to
take the meta exam
for certified digital marketing
associate which is an independent
certification for meta and you can
achieve associate alumni status when you
complete the program so we
will talk about the meta advantage
the program includes ask me anything
sessions by meta in a master session by
meta experts
and then as I mentioned you receive a
voucher which allows you to take
the
certification exam
the program also prepares you to succeed
at that exam so that's an additional
benefit of this program
we talk about the prerequisites and this
is a
postgraduate type of program in the
sense that you must have a bachelor's
degree but it can be in any discipline
not restricted to a business degree or a
marketing degree or a technology degree
you can come in from any background
although it is desirable that you have
digital marketing understanding or
experience it is not required
um it is required however that you have
two years of work experience
in some formal work environment so that
you have an understanding of how
organizations work and how digital
marketing can fit into their
business cycle so
with that said I will ask this question
which is
how much experience do you have in the
members of the audience here so
watching the poll
and we'll just leave this open for
another 10 seconds because it's pretty
straightforward
so I will close the poll in five
four three
two
one
and we have about a third of our
audience or people who are still working
on their degree
um
for that part of our audience this
program you're a little bit premature
for this program but for the folks who
are in The Working World and have at
least two years of experience
this is a great program for you
so let's continue
and we'll discuss how this program
prepares you
so we build up your
capabilities step by step and there's a
set of core
courses within the program
then there's a set of electives that
allow you to look at other specialties
the program begins with a program
induction which is simply an orientation
to the digital platform and what the
curriculum will include what's expected
of you in terms of attendance and
completing projects and then you move
into the basic digital marketing so
Professor subject would you like to
discuss this
yeah sure thank you Stuart yeah so uh as
as Stuart suggested the Prof the you
know you have a product program
induction and then you start with the
introduction to digital marketing in
introduction to digital marketing we
give you a brief idea about you know
what is expected for this course from
this course and how this course will be
taking forward to you okay then we have
a SEO module in which you will be taken
uh through the you know different tricks
and techniques and tactics to you know
that are utilized in SEO that you know
even with SEO there's something called
as white hat SEO and you know black hat
SEO so you will be taken you will be
making you will be understanding the
differences between white hat SEO and
black hat SEO right so even with how
ethically also which is called as the
white hat SEO now ethically also you can
make an effort towards your uh ranking
website higher and higher in the search
engine Google search engine results page
okay so that's a part of SEO
and these days pretty much every
companies like every company has a you
know uh an SEO specialist and on and
works on SEO okay so SEO is being you
know very much optimized by each and
every uh you know uh Brands these days
the second comes uh your PPC which is
the pay-per-click So within the paper
click module you'll be covering the
digital display ads uh as well as the
search ads so how a search as it is been
made
what creatives what kind of content
should the search ad have how much of
information to give uh are you uh how
much of input if you uh if you remember
if you show you know search something on
the uh search engine result page you
will see uh you know a limited amount of
information which you can skim through
and make a decision on whether you want
to click on this website and go further
or dig deeper you want to get much more
insights on this or not or you want to
go to the next one right so how much of
the search results what content should
be included in that is is being it has
to be taken into a consideration you
know you decide on that display ads what
kind of pictures you know what what kind
of you know in information within the
display AD should be there where are the
website that you can publish your
display ads which websites matches with
the you know the product or the service
uh offered okay all these activities
however display ad is being made so all
these activities are taken care in the
pay-per-click uh module okay
the social media marketing module you'll
be taking through Facebook ads okay uh
first of all it will talking about the
different kinds of social media
platforms their importances how
different kinds of social media platform
works and for which kind of audiences
and which kind of content okay so all
these will be taken care of and then you
talk about you know uh how a Facebook ad
is being made you know what what is the
procedure of Facebook ad how you can
include and exclude certain demographics
and all uh how are LinkedIn ads or
advertisements on LinkedIn works so all
these will be taken care of within the
Facebook also like you know as you might
not you might know that these days right
you know that your Instagram is also
being a part of Facebook only right
Instagram powered by Facebook you always
see whenever you open the Instagram app
right so majority of your Facebook ads
majority of your Instagram ads are also
being a part of your Facebook ads so
they are run by the Facebook uh
ad manager right
so you can utilize uh you know duplex
you'll be talking so one of the
important aspect of web analytics is to
understand your audience right so it's
not about running ad and keep keep on
running ads and keep spending your
budgets right you have to also analyze
you have to also understand right that
what is your actually how is your
audience actually behaving whether they
are having much more higher bounce rate
whether they are having much more you
know
um spending much more time on that so
all these are taken care into web
analytics marketing analytics will also
be taken care of you know how the
product and the brand actually takes
into consideration with the uh website
or the social media analytics so these
all will be part of your you know
marketing analytics where they will be
talking about
um how to you know understand consumer
behavior and what else could be done in
order to have much more you know value
from the
uh from the digital marketing
perspective and then at the finally you
will be
the digital marketing Capstone project
all all these modules will be running
you will be simultaneously working on
your projects as well and in between if
you have any questions they will be also
be resolved by The Faculty who will be
taking these separate modules uh
so
I don't know yeah I just wanted to
mention that when you look at the list
of electives along the right hand side
these electives are all included in the
price of the program so it's not a
matter of uh adding on an elective at an
additional cost these are all available
to you at your discretion So based on
your level of interest in in each of
these areas and your time availability
you can choose to engage in as many of
these as you
want and we certainly
especially uh
recommend that you engage in The Meta
Master session and the digital leader
master classes because these will bring
you perspectives from industry that are
difficult to get elsewhere
um
thank you Professor for that overview
and as you can see the other
electives cover a number of different
other specializations so
this is one way you can tailor the
program to your own interests and needs
and again tools and platforms that
you'll use uh I don't know Professor if
you wanted to comment on this in terms
of
how people will use these during the
program in the different projects and
case studies that they do but
folks will be using
all of these and not just learning about
them but actually getting hands-on
experience with them as you go through
the different modules and appropriately
use these in the projects that you do
within each course so at the end of the
process when you list these skills and
tools on your resume you will have
practical examples to be able to show
from your portfolio that's very
important
and then
I think Professor subject if you'd like
to talk again about the Capstone project
and how
ties everything together because this is
a chance to elaborate on that a bit
the Capstone project uh yeah am I
audible yeah yes
so uh the Capstone
project is you know whatever uh whatever
the learnings that you have from each
modules right uh that will be uh you
know you would be able to apply that in
the Capstone project uh Learners can you
know base caption project on the
industries so whenever whichever
industry you are working you can select
you can create your own you know uh um
problem from there and then you can try
and working on that right
um they will be having real world data
sets or with virtual labs and Hands-On
learning so even uh with you know as uh
Stuart just mentioned you will be
working on different kinds of platforms
like uh stem semrash you you know Uber
suggest so different kinds of digital
platforms which are already available to
you at your fingertips so you will be
utilizing that in order to understand
much more about
yeah
businesses right and uh while these
modules are already running with you you
can you know try Hands-On on different
kinds of different kinds of websites try
check out your competitors uh in your
industry and see how they are doing
right so that will be as a part of you
know you can always come up and ask
questions about that and elab you know
get much more
um extra you know take much more from
um the course and definitely that will
help you in enriching your experience
about you know digital marketing yeah
and thank you for that again
um so
it's important to note that when you're
doing the Capstone project you're
working in conjunction with your
instructor so that they're keeping track
of you and Advising you on a weekly
basis as you go through the program so I
just want to mention the learning
environment the you use this one
interface one platform to manage your
curriculum it'll show you what classes
uh constitute your program
how to enroll in each one how to unlock
access to the next one in the program
once you finish the one you're in it
gives you the live virtual classroom
environment it allows you to do your
tests assessments and projects including
that all important Capstone project on
the same platform so that all the tools
that you need are there
and made available to you in a virtual
environment
it keeps track of your progress and
gives you prompts if you are becoming uh
delinquent or if you're getting behind
in the program it'll give you
encouragement to catch up and
suggestions on how to do that and we'll
unlock certificates for each course
along the way so that you can have that
trail of achievement that leads up to
the final certificate when you complete
the Capstone project
um the platform includes support tools
that include the
social
Community where you can turn to both
your professors and your peers for
uh
guidance and assistance if you're stuck
at three o'clock in the morning while
you're working on a project you'll have
somebody to turn to and ask a question
of we also have that 24 7 support desk
from Simply learned that allows you to
ask those questions of our support staff
both on the subject matter and on the
use of the platform itself so you're
never alone in the process
and as you've met today uh it's a Sunday
Professor Bindu and Professor Super G
are the program directors
and faculty advisors for this program
so Professor Sandeep if you'd like to go
through the
um
so uh thanks a lot again Stuart so uh
I am one of the program director along
with Professor Bindu and I am basically
part of the marketing department in IMT
ghaziabad and you know that IMT
ghaziabad is known for its marketing
department and the courses I take my
research is primarily application of
technology and sales and marketing and
prior to joining uh the Academy I worked
long time in Industry with large
companies like IBM Ericsson Siemens so
um wish you all the best and you would
have the best of learning in this
program
okay
uh
good evening I am
that's why I mentioned I'm not teaching
this program
with Professor deep I coordinate this
program
is around more than 20 years uh last
year I have been the Academia uh in my
uh in my career and the IRT subjects
like cognition behavior cross-cultural
management and do research and uh which
are applicable to the sales employee
like I don't self leadership uh or maybe
ethical behavior for the sales force so
I do research on this area I welcome to
you this program and we hope you will be
make best of uh this program and it will
help in your career also wish you very
all the best
thank you Professor so uh once again
welcome everybody and uh very good
evening to all so I am Gupta I completed
my PhD from IIT kharagpur uh and before
joining to IMT so I worked at uh one of
the another B schools that you might
know is not tap me okay so my area of
specialization is marketing and subjects
like digital marketing marketing
management brand management these are
some of the subjects that I uh Teach as
well as research on so uh that's all
from my end and the digital marketing
has been you know I have been teaching
digital marketing since the start of my
career in academics so I really feel
much more motivated towards the subject
and its subject is very close to my
heart so I I wish you all the very best
and I hope maximum of you could able to
take the maximum benefit out of this uh
course okay thank you thank you very
much professors
um and again over to you
thank you again
and we want to mention a couple of
success stories
one of them from Aaron who was able to
leverage a program to reach us 40 salary
hike
which is a pretty uh phenomenal
result
um and then we have uh RG who
really enjoyed the program got a lot out
of it and is using that to
um
further his journey into digital
marketing so
we hope that we can add your success
stories to this
log of this roster of successful
program completers
to help with that simply learn provides
additional benefit as part of this
program
this benefit for Learners in India
extends for six months after
the uh completion of your certificate
and it's done in conjunction with IIM
jobs so a couple of parts are accessible
to all on the lifelong basis having to
do with access to webinars Career events
simply learned offers online we also
as part of the program let you build up
this portfolio of real world projects
that let you uh demonstrate your
experience to potential employers
but the job assist services with IIM
jobs extend for six months after you
complete the certificate and you can
access them as much or as little as you
want we recommend that that you take
full advantage if you're looking for a
new position in digital marketing
includes the access to the IIM jobs
portal six-month premium membership
and this allows you to do your job
search from their network of employers
and job listings
do it discreetly so that you're not on
one of the more public
job boards like uh Peter glass store
where you might be
visible to your employer this is more
discreet but also we especially
encourage you to take advantage of the
resume review and rewrite service and
the one-on-one interview service resume
review and rewrite is important because
in the modern world a human being will
not see your resume until an automated
system has passed it through an AI bot
and matched your
qualifications skills and experience
against the the specifications of the
job description
so knowing how to write your resume in a
format that the AI bot can access that
information about you and make the best
use of it to filter you into the process
rather than out the important skill at
the same time your resume will end up in
front of a human being if the guy passes
it and so you do want it to be appealing
to the eye
and when it lands on someone's desk or
screen but
attention grabbing and get you that
interview so balancing those two
objectives in the resume process uh very
important art form and resume writer
will help you
develop that professionally
uh similarly with the one-on-one
interview service
you get to the interview process as you
know from
being hired
you have to go through many layers of
interviews starting with the phone
screen from a recruiter or an HR person
onto technical interviews with potential
uh
colleagues and and supervisors who want
to know about your abilities and skills
to the management fit interviews that
talk about your fit with the company
culture your work ethic your ability to
be a team player each of these
interviews has a different flavor and it
requires you to put forward a different
side of yourself and so being able to
practice each of these types of
interviews one-on-one with a live human
being really a valuable benefit as well
so
as I mentioned we do a number of
different
um
webinars on a weekly basis that talk
about different
technology Fields job skills
um
Career Development skills job search
techniques and so this is available to
you on a lifelong basis these are at no
cost
and here's some examples of the case
studies and projects you'll be working
on to build up your portfolio so
looking at case studies from companies
like Domino's
pizza delivery
Volkswagen give India
you'll be looking at um
the non-profit sector you'll be looking
at uh the general topic of sponsored
search these are all different topics
that you'll be addressing
and your Capstone project will allow you
to pick from a domain of your choice
create a digital marketing campaign
that you can then
use as a
portfolio example of how you approach
digital marketing problems and solve
them
based on what the professors and I have
shared with you today
are you
potentially interested
in
taking this program so I'm going to open
this poll
we'll leave this open for about 15
seconds because it's a yes or no
question
so do get your answers in
and I will close the poll in five
seconds from now
four three
two one
hit submit
here is the result
three quarters of our audience are
interested in the program
this would be then a great time for us
to talk about it
how to get started
but we'll talk about enrollment steps
the first thing to know is that the next
cohort
for classes starting in May you can take
an induction session as
early as 26th of April so that's about a
week away
and
um
the as I said the live classes start on
20 May
start by sending us an email at ask us
at simplylearn.net
and when you email us we will evaluate
your application we'll verify your
prerequisites including your education
and your work experience
and based on that we'll
determine if you're eligible to join the
program
if you are you'll get an admission
letter
I've just put the email address into the
chat so it's accessible to you
and when we say hurry limited seats are
available you might ask why in a digital
program there's a limitation on
a number of people who can participate
in any given cohort the reason is that
this is uh done with live instruction
where the
instructors will be asking you questions
they'll be responding to your questions
and in order to be able to give
sufficient attention to everyone in the
cohort we limit the size to about 25 to
30 people maximum
so
if you would like to participate in the
20 May cohort please do get started
right away
the program fees are one lock one
thousand nine hundred ninety nine rupee
and you can use Emi financing as low as
3471 a month
or attending this session today you can
claim a 20 discount off of those fees
which is a fabulous bonus
and really worth taking advantage of if
you want to get into that 20 May cohort
so please reach out to us and ask us at
simplylearn.net we will be sending you a
follow-up email with more details as
well but you can get started by
emailing us and
I'm going to ask the three quarters of
the people who are interested
how soon would you be interested in
starting do you want to try to get into
the Mako heart are you looking
potentially at one month or two after
that or are you looking further down the
road
we'll leave this open for about 10 more
seconds
and I'll close this poll in five four
free
three two one
full
and
close to half of our audience want to
join in the May cohort or maybe June
July so that's great and please do email
us at ask us at simplylearn.net to get
started for those looking further down
the road and for some of you who are
maybe still in school please also email
us at ask us at simplylearn.net and we
can keep you informed about future
cohorts of the program and discuss your
needs more details so
we encourage all of you to to
participate there at this point I'm
going to
move over to the question and answers
invite our professors to join
on video
and I want to go through some of the
questions that have come in the question
and answer and we had a couple also in
the chat so
um
adarsh asked about job placement and I
wanted to mention that our
job assist services are not job
placement but they are assistance with
your job search so we don't guarantee a
job placement or arrange internships but
we do provide you with the tools for
conducting your own job search
um
rasham asks about if there are specific
courses about SEO and email marketing
and Mr Super G you could reiterate that
for
yeah yeah yeah uh so I I think uh is
there any are there any specific courses
about SEO or email marketing so there
are modules about them so we'll be
taking different modules we have a
module of uh on SEO uh you have a module
uh you can also be covering some of the
email marketing aspects
um but not specific as only SEO it comes
with a bundle of other digital marketing
uh techniques as well
um adarsh asks about the minimum salary
package after completion of course and
of course we don't guarantee any minimum
salary package oh but you can see
that was my cat leaning against my uh
webcam uh you can see on job boards uh
different availabilities the did you
have a perspective on that uh Professor
Sunday professor
so
um we cannot say that what is the
minimum salary level do not guarantee it
as you don't but obviously this is a
like new skills and if you learn it uh
obviously it will help in your present
job to be more effective or to get a new
job if you want to really move to
digital marketing Arena so do you you
can use this course one is like you are
doing your job but uh how to use digital
technology to be more effective on your
presence of or people who actually want
to get into one of the roles in the
digital marketing or analytic also
nowadays there are lots of analytic on
the data from digital domain so um
obviously it will be lead to better
salary but we do not have any data to
justify that or tell you exact figure
[Music]
it will help you uh to grow in your
career
and if you're looking to to join the
digital marketing field from outside you
can as I mentioned check the different
public uh job boards and see what the
prevailing salaries are
numbers are publicly available so
um but as we showed earlier one of our
graduates uh was very happy to report a
40 salary hike so that's a great uh
great result
um I'm going to look into the chat as
I've seen
like I've seen all the messages from the
q a
but we did have some in the chat here
somebody is also duration of the course
or something
yes and the duration of the course is
five months
um
so Vijay Kumar asks can you select only
one topic from the electives list or
the can you pick more than one
Professor super sheet
uh I think uh professors uh I think
Stuart you would take that answer
question yeah
the the course includes all of the uh
electives and you can take as many of
them as you see fit uh based on your
level of Interest which subjects
interest you most how much time you have
so
um you're not limited
and if you decide you wanted to take one
or two of the electives and realize that
you were having a lot of good results
from learning and wanted to take more
that's also available to you so that's
an important thing to know about the
program is that you you can pretty much
choose off of that menu much some kind
of an all you can eat kind of menu for
the collectives
um yeah
see
we had a question for
um from thakur in the chat which is
um what is the the future what is the
potential for people working in other
areas who want to Pivot to digital
marketing
one of you like to take that
um
yeah if you're working in a for example
somebody who might be working at a
technical field or might be working in
uh
completely different aspect of
opportunity to give you a lot of skills
and knowledge and we also do hands on
work so it's just not theories you will
also know exactly how digital marketing
is being used and also you would have a
brand name of IMT ghaziabad and some
support of placement with simply learn
so uh but it also depends on many things
like how many years of experience you
have you already have too many years of
experience so that may act as a negative
factor but who are having like few years
of experience but if they want to switch
I think it would be easier for them so
anybody else you want to join anything
And to clarify we have a specific
question from JD on that same subject
who says he's from a financial industry
as a service executive
um who doesn't want to change his field
but wants to benefit from this
certification how would somebody in
financial uh the financial industry
benefit from Gaining digital marketing
skills
so as we uh you know uh I would take
that Stuart thank you for the question
so even even if you are not you are
planning to switch your career right
it's not uh as a you're not uh taking on
that but definitely you are living in
the world of digital right so it's a
very much a digital era that we are
living in so how these things are
happening so this gives you a knowledge
of know-how of how things are happening
right moreover as we as I talked about
it's uh like you know how to utilize
LinkedIn uh very effectively for your
you know uh creating your own personal
brand so that's where you know social
media marketing works so you are
eventually somewhere or the other
marketing for yourself so you can
definitely add those skills to improve
your you know uh to improve or you know
to enhance your uh career but uh it's
completely fine if you don't want to
change your career right so it's it's
not a career changing course as well so
it's majorly enhances your skills gives
you a know-how plus there's a
certification attached to it so it gives
you a benefit of you know a valid
certification to help you you know if
you want to switch as well sometimes in
the future so definitely it works in
that way yeah and a perspective on uh
jadeep's question also is that if your
financial service executive and you need
to understand how your institution
um Services its customers whether
they're consumers or business customers
um understanding digital Market
marketing techniques and skills will
help you understand how your
organization is presenting itself the
promises it's making and you can have a
better
chance of influencing that and
understanding how your concerns as a
service executive get reflected in those
marketing programs so that's a really a
valuable aspect of the program
um
the niche asks uh Ganesha if this course
can be available in the Hindi language
and this is presented in English because
it becomes the uh most
um
accessible in terms of common
accessibility across
Indian Marketplace so unfortunately we
can't accommodate that at this point
however there's
you know always in future there will be
tools available for individuals to do
AI based translations and that type of
thing so while the instruction won't be
in in the
um
there will be
you may be able to find some tools that
will let you
um
understand the material better
then
I wanted so a question from Rahul and
this is an interesting question
um because it touches I think both on
Professor super duty and Professor
bindusek areas of expertise will it
cover UI ux designs
as well
with respect to designing SEO or digital
marketing um
tools and campaigns
yeah uh so uh definitely not UI ux is a
part of this because you know in terms
of SEO we are not talking about we are
not trying to develop or design the
website right it's not a part of website
designing that's a very separate course
we are trying to utilize strategies in
order in which the already existing
website can be made to rank higher so
that's the process of SEO so it's a
search engine optimization not the
website designing right so definitely UI
ux is not a part of it so uh that's what
uh is from my India
but yeah
Within
website optimization and that type of
thing you touch on that but um this is
not particularly at UI ux design course
although considerations in UA ux you
just user interface and user experience
um will be part of some of the courses
so
with that I think we have come to the
end of the questions available let me
see if there's one there are two that
came in
we are running out of time here
that completes the questions we've seen
if we missed if I did miss your question
uh anyone in the audience please uh
accept my apologies and you can also
contact our learning Consultants at ask
us at simplylearn.net to follow up but
at this point I want to ask you in the
audience one last question
and
this question is do you want us to reach
out to you and also if you want to Res
a digital
excuse me Zoom is going to kick me off
hold on a second
I'll be back
apologize for that it has to do with
when I start sharing my screen again so
um I apologize for that Interruption I
will share this poll but I was
mentioning if you want to receive a
digital proof of attendance for
tonight's webinar uh you can answer yes
this question yes to this question if
you want us to reach out to you and give
you more information or answer your
questions so oop sorry
hit the button too early hold on a
second let me do that again just take a
moment
foolish
steak
let's try that one more time I apologize
for that
fumbling of my finger
okay and we will leave this in
all right thank you
thank you
foreign
apology for that last
event that happened we are at the end of
our program and I want to thank
Professor Bindu professor subijit and
Professor Sandeep
for being so generous with their time
and their knowledge and being so patient
with our technical difficulties with the
zoom platform so thank you all again
thank you thank you thank you everyone
thank you
and we just want to say uh thank you to
everyone for being here we hope we can
welcome you into the
um
Learning Community for
IMT ghaziabad and simply learn
you see a do it on the screen that can
take you to the
uh webinar page but that ends our
webinar thanks again
foreign
thank you